hi everyone seems like a lot of you know
me already for those of you don't it is
fun to be speaking at yet another Python
conference I feel like James is trying
to convert me to python mmm he does is
not going to work but it's nice that it
keeps trying today I want to talk about
two of my favorite topics bayesian
regression and penalize regression we're
going to walk through both of them how
they can be used and towards the end
will actually talk about how they could
be viewed as two sides at the same coin
so I guess show of hands a small room
who here considers themselves a bayesian
all right who here considers themselves
a frequentist trying to be okay you can
you can do the duality all right let me
see a view bayesian switch you how many
of you hate frequent disks all right and
only one frequent test how many of you
hate bayesian your kinks you're trying
to be a bayesian all right it's not as
big a deal it used to be back in the 70s
but what was that it does all science
back in the 70s used to be that Bayesian
zand freakin disturbs like a royal
battle royale between them but nowadays
they get along the general idea behind
it all at least from what we're going to
talk about today is just rooted in
regular regression I assume that
everyone in this room knows what a
regression is correct fitting a cloud
appoint a straight line through cloud of
points yes this is made of GG vis the
next iteration of ggplot and of course
regression can be extended naturally to
a hyperplane instead of fitting a
straight line through a cloud of points
you're putting a hyperplane through
crowd a cloud of points again no big
deal to anyone in this room you probably
all know exactly what I'm talking about
the math behind regression everyone
knows very simple y equals x beta plus
epsilon where y is your response vector
X is your design matrix including a
column of one's for the intercept beta
is your vector coefficients one for each
variable plus an intercept and epsilon
is your noise term I'm going to make a
very strong point here I think I'd say
this every time I talk about regression
they are not independent and dependent
variables there predictors and outcome
and responses inputs and outcomes saying
independent dependent really bothers me
a because they sound too similar it's
hard to screw up
but more importantly probability theory
says if X is independent of Y why is
independent of X you can't have the x's
be independent the independent and the Y
be dependent I know that's not what they
mean but just just greats me the wrong
way so we're going to throw those terms
out the whole idea here is solving for
the betas getting your coefficients
right so most of you probably know that
beta hat equals x transpose X inverse X
transpose Y we solved that using a bit
of calculus and some algebra pretty easy
to figure out except this can be
difficult computationally we have a
large matrix taking an inversion can be
slow you have a 10,000 x 10000 which is
not beyond the realm of reason and
modern statistics that's a hard problem
to invert so we usually use some sort of
approximation like a troll esky
decomposition or QR decomposition all
right everyone everyone good everyone
knows the stuff in pursuing is pretty
basic so far awesome then you know that
this works great until you run into many
predictors and you hit the curse of
dimensionality everyone sort of this
unless you're Andy Gelman in which case
you say is the blessing of
dimensionality he believes that adds
structure to your problem he likes more
data I think he's thinking going from 10
to 15 variables I don't think he's
assuming 10,000 variables but we'll get
into that so you can imagine the big
cube and I might have some of you see me
talk before you might have seen us the
big cube is your data you have three
dimensional data space and your little
cube is your local space and you're
trying to use local methods to estimate
the big space everyone knows that a
regression is a simply a local estimator
like a sliding window problem is that
you want to capture as much of the
volume of the big cube using the little
cube and trying to use as little surface
area as possible want to maximize the
volume about decreasing I guess the
sides if you ever want to learn about
like hypercubes google flatland carl
sagan he's a really cool video from I
think it's from his universe thing what
was it called who cosmos yes I think
it's based on that but of course this
generalizes to hypercubes cause you get
multiple dimensions you get into
hypercubes don't worry too much about
that we can see this this graph shows
for a given number of dimensions that
each line is a different number
jin's in order to capture a certain
fraction of the volume of the big cube
how long the sides of the little cube
need to be as a proportion of the big
cube so let's say we have 10 dimensions
which by the way is not a lot of
dimensions if you want to capture even
ten percent of the volume of the big
cube your little cube needs to be eighty
percent the size of the big cube all of
a sudden it's not such a local space
anymore so when you have this high
dimensionality you can have exploded
confidence intervals you could have
unstable predictions everything can go
bad there are a few ways to get around
that my two personal favorites are
weekly informative priors and penalize
regressions so that's what we're going
to talk about today first up weekly
informative priors this all stems from
Bayes theorem I show of hands who knows
Bayes theorem everyone purva eaves all
right everyone knows Bayes theorem great
then everyone knows how it's derived
right probability of a times B equals
probability of a time's probability of B
given a you can flip those around and
you get Bayes theorem no surprise even
back in the 70s this wasn't
controversial bayesian regression might
have been bayesian methods might have
been but not based there this is just a
standard law of probability which we
derived using algebra we can rewrite
this in statistical terms where theta is
your parameters could be the
coefficients in the regression or it
could be a mean anything you want to
estimate and X is your data the
denominator is the probability of the
data which means you need to sum it over
all possibilities of the parameters and
this integral can give us trouble
because it's a difficult integral to
work with and integrals when
computations can be difficult but this
all breaks down to four main parts that
one sees the four parts here which boil
down to the posterior is equal to the
likelihood times the prior over a
normalizing constant and since it's just
a normalizing constant we can get rid of
it and say the posterior is
proportionate to the like
times the prior so all of my bayesian
xin the crowd you've seen this right any
non bayesian in there any questions then
what gets us great essentially the
likelihood is just your regular
frequentist estimate and the prior is
your prior beliefs on the coefficients
so for bayesian regression it starts out
the same why is distributed normally x
times beta of the standard deviation of
Sigma again this is just for gaussian
regression you want to do logistic
Poisson whatever else just use a
different astre bution but for gaussian
this is how you do it and the beta has a
prior distribution in this case i'm
using a co she LS because i want like a
weekly informative prior you could use
any prior you want that as long as that
makes sense and is tractable actually
doesn't need to be tractable and they
don't even need to be real prior it
could be like pseudo priors but i'm just
using the coachee because i find that a
co she 0 2.5 is a nice standard prior
it's a nice default prior to use it has
this really strong effect and of course
i like visual visualizing everything so
these are two ways to see cosi priors
the one on the left is weekly
informative it's a co she 2.5 and the
one on the right is a strongly
informative prior that's a co she won
does any does everyone know the Koshi
distribution alright forget if your nose
okay well this is the cosi distribution
right way to see it's a very strong
spike and i have it centered at 0
because i'm trying to shrink my
coefficients down to zero has a very
strong spike edit center then its scale
variable either one or two point five
tells you how spread out it is notice
the scales the co-ceo of a scale of one
on the right goes from what negative 500
to positive 50 where the scale 2.5 is
going from negative four thousand a
positive thousand so it's much more
spread out its weekly informative it
doesn't have all the mass in the center
and look how on the left i'm only goes
up to a baby about 13% whereas on the
right it goes up to thirty four percent
meaning the right hand side if you use
that as a prior it's really going to
pull the coefficients towards zero
whereas the left hand prior its weekly
informative it'll nudge it toward zero
but not really force it to be there so
is everyone cool the differences between
the weekly informative in a strongly
informative awesome and so you do your
multiplication you likely at times your
prior and you get a posterior like this
in this case is the normal distribution
times the Koshi i cancelled out some of
the terms like 1 over the square root of
2 pi because it's just constants you
take them out we're just worried about
proportionality and when you're doing
beijing regression you're actually
looking at the posterior distribution
and you can visualize that with a
density plot we can see a standard
regression on the left but this is
actually based on a real regression
problem now I took voting polling vote
polling data election polling data from
1964 to try to figure out the
probability of voting for the Republican
candidate and this particular variable
I'm looking at is the variable for if
the person is african-american so if the
person is Ephraim african-american
what's the probability of voting
Republican in 1964 and you can see with
a standard Gaussian regression i-i'm
sorry this is standard logistic
regression is the logistic problem now
you get a credible interval there's a no
longer confidence intervals or credible
intervals there are slight differences
is all about the density and of a
credible interval you actually have a
ninety-five percent chance that the
estimate is within their unlike
confidence intervals which is if you
repeat the test repeatedly then is
ninety-five percent chance of being in
here a credible interval there's
actually ninety-five percent chance
right now that it's in there and we get
this density plot notice the scales for
a standard logistic regression you're
getting it spread out across from
negative 500 deposit of 1500 and you
only ever get a mass of about point one
percent whereas if you just use a weekly
informative prior you've shrunk that
credible interval from like negative
eight to positive to negative 8 2
negative 2 and you get like 35-percent
mass in the middle you're much more
certain about what you're doing already
that's a nice right you want you want
greater certainty we can visualize this
using a coefficient plot the logistic
regression on the left and the weekly
informative Bayesian regression on the
right
for those of you haven't seen these
coefficient plots it's an idea I totally
ripped off from Andy Gelman he had on
his one of his our packages I just made
it look prettier and work work a little
differently and the dot represents a
point estimate for your parameter though
wings represent the confidence intervals
the fat wing is the one standard
deviation cut one standard error
confidence interval and the thin ones
are two standard deviations sorry two
standard errors on the left-hand plot
you can see it couldn't even estimate
some of the parameters and let's look at
the parameter second from the bottom for
black and for education unknown you came
and see the point estimate you couldn't
even see the point estimate sorry you
came to see the point estimate because
it's way off the screen and the
confidence interval spreads the whole
screen that confidence interval really
goes to like negative a thousand deposit
of 500 it's crazy how wide that is but
as soon as you put a weekly informative
prior it shrinks it down to negative 4
and actually a decent confidence
interval it's amazing what this did if
you want to see how obviously this is
out of place we can use what Gelman
calls the secret weapon it's when you
fit a model again and again and again
let's say you have data over a number of
years you fit a separate model for each
year you can see trends over time how
that variable has changed and you can
see here 19 again we're plotting this
just for the coefficient for if someone
is african-american and you can see in
1964 its way out of whack not only is
the estimate much smaller than the other
estimates the confidence interval is
just crazy and I had to zoom in on this
because if I didn't zoom in on the plot
you everything would look like it's
right around zero that's how badly these
confidence intervals are but if you just
simply apply weekly informative prior
all of a sudden 1964 is a lot like the
other years it is very important to note
that I did not use information from the
other years to calculate this it's very
tempting to think hey I went through got
1960 got 1968 took information from
there and fit 1964 not the case every
year here was fit completely
independently of the other years
it's just using this prior information I
even prior information I had no prior
information I just put a constraint on
the variables to try to drag them toward
zero and putting the graph side by side
you can really see what a dramatic
difference it makes unless uncertainty
is better I think everyone agrees and
using this weekly informative prior does
that everyone cool all right awesome
there are a few ways to solve this
problem to solve a bayesian regression
you can use the expectation-maximization
algorithm which you take an expectation
step you take a maximization step fairly
easy to do now that's not true bayesian
true bayesian you want to draw samples
from the posterior distribution so you
want to use markov chain monte carlo and
if you're going to use markov chain
monte carlo i suggest using stan stan is
a new probabilistic programming language
from indy Gilman's team and it's
actually not an acronym it's named after
stanislav alam has anyone heard of
stanislav ghulam one guy you're a real
bayesian right he is the co-inventor of
MC MC and also the co-inventor of the
hydrogen bomb he invented mcmc at the
one of the nuclear research labs to
figure out what was going on with the
nuclear reactions and what he's holding
there is called a fermi ack it was
invented by Enrico Fermi there was a
physical Monte Carlo simulator this back
before they had grill computers to do
this stuff they had to use a physical
simulator I didn't know how he did it
with that mean this looks like there's
like ten moving parts there it's pretty
amazing so Stan code sort of looks like
this and I when I said there's no going
to be no code I guess I said there will
be a little bit pseudocode it looks like
this and you can call Stan from our
Python Julia or the command line so it's
really it's really open really operative
you can use it from a knee interface
you'd like you want to get your data in
Python munja put it together then call
Stan you can you want to do it in our
you can do it it's really cool stuff
they've built it's much faster than bugs
and Jags it is the new way to do
bayesian programming no it is a bayesian
method so it's still going to be slower
than a frequentist method but it lets
you fit more complicated models
including hierarchical
any questions about Beijing regression
assume everyone knew what i was talking
about that so everyone so quiet awesome
all right then on to my next favorite
topic penalized aggression who here uses
penalize regression no one will be all
right I'm in a room full of asians I
guess that's why no one uses penalize
regression all right I love penalize
regression in fact I think this is one
of the greatest innovations and
statistics in the past 15 years it
really allows us to do much more with
our data it just like bayesian
aggression it starts with ordinary
least-squares everyone know its ordinary
least-squares you're just trying to
minimize the sum of squares but penalize
regression ads on a penalty term it's
lambda that's your penalty parameter the
bigger lambda is the bigger the penalty
smaller lambda smaller penalty times the
sum of this of the coefficients to the Q
power some of the absolutes are the
coefficients to the q power now Q can
take on any sort of numbers if it's zero
it's subset selection because then the
penalty is just counting the number of
parameters if it's one it's the lasso if
it's too which Ridge aggression who here
has heard of lasso regression who here
is her to Ridge regression have you guys
used it now you just heard of you've
used it cool different penalties can
give you different shapes and no q does
not need to be an integer if you want to
have a nice analytic solution yeah make
it a cue to make it an l2 penalty then
you take a derivative and everything if
you don't mind using algorithms it could
be point 1 point 5 12 for whatever you
would like these shaped yeah question
well for Q it's l2 norm for one is l1
norm great yep and so these things
represent if you have just two
predictors where the predictors would
lie where the constraint region is it's
just like beta 1 plus beta 2 but it
could be beta square 1 squared plus beta
2 squared or whatever and it forms a
simple geometry at this point the sharp
corners for Q equals 1 and point 5 means
it's not differentiable but right there
is where the predictor for that that
predictor would be zero okay everyone
cool these constraint regions all right
the most common penalties are the last
so in the ridge which are l1 and l2
machine learning people call it l1
penalization l2 penalization sin
statisticians call it lasso and ridge
really depends what you want to call it
last I believe for lease angle
subsetting insult shrinkage operations I
forget is equity stands for but they can
be visualized like this the circle is
the constraint region and the red
ellipses are the contours of OLS
regression where the contours hit the
restraint region is your solution if it
hits at the corner of the diamond for
lasso that particular variable will be 0
if you have multiple dimensions which
you're going to you'll have multiple
corners it's not just a four-sided
diamond it's a multi-sided diamond and
each corner represents a zeroing out of
a certain predictor and where it
represents the circle where it hits a
circle that's just where the last of the
ridge regression intersects with the OLS
and whereas the lasso does variable
selection and will completely zero out
and eliminate variables the ridge
regression just sort of smoothes
variables out smoothes the coefficients
out amongst correlated variables and
gets things towards 0 but never actually
0 and you can fit this you get the ridge
has an analytic solution the lasso you
use these angle regression to fit to get
a solution now whereas the lasso does
variable selection and the road is just
a shrinkage you're not stuck of one or
the other you can combine them into the
elastic net so who's heard of the
elastic net
dan chen there you go you've heard the
elastic neck the elastic net is a
dynamic combination of the l1 and l2
penalties we've replaced the penalty
term right after the lambda with this
expression on the bottom which is one
minus alpha times a half times the l2
norm of beta plus alpha times the l1
norm of beta and again the l2 norm is
just the sum of the squares of the
coefficients the l1 is the sum of the
absolutes of the coefficients if you set
alpha 2 1 you have a lasso regression
because you just do basic map set off
with a 1 and you're left of the last
penalty you said 20 you left with the
ridge penalty and somewhere in between
is the elastic net if you set it in
between you can get a nice combination
of l1 and l2 so you get variable
selection and you get shrinkage so it's
a nice combination the this was
discovered discovered invented found out
by the Stanford guys hasty trip Gianni
Friedman Chow a bunch of them put it
together and they've written a program
for this called glm net generalized
linear models elastic net that took 73
lines of fortran code so a it's written
in fortran which is amazing because I
means a super fastener really cool be
it's only 73 lines which just shows the
simplicity of the algorithm in fact this
algorithm can be fit in the same order
of operations as an ordinary
least-squares operation which is really
quite amazing and it is available as
both an R and a matlab package there is
a site kit learn package but it's not
written by the Stanford guys it's
written by other people I don't know who
wrote it but I've been told their
computer engineers but I've been told it
works pretty well but the other the glm
that package is written by the package
authors itself yes I think you're kept
picking it up in the original
formulation of the elastic net there is
no gamma there but if you use our
software you can actually find to an
individual penalties on each parameter
so that's where the gamma is it's a
matrix of parameter penalties I was
actually a matrix of multipliers for the
lambda penalty on each of the predictors
so that gives you even more power it's
not across the board penalty you can
modulate it depending on which
predictors if you have one predictor
that must be in the model you know tuned
down as penalty we have a predictor of
that a you really don't care about two
and up its penalty that's what the gamma
is for visually the elastic net falls
somewhere in between the lasso in the
ridge the outer circle is the ridge as
you saw before it's a circular
constraint region and the diamond in the
middle is the lasso sorry the diamond on
the inside is the lasso whereas the
elastic net is the red line that goes in
between and while looks circular if you
look at the vertices there are actual
singularities and that's what lets you
get a sparse coefficient vector back
which means it's zeroed out predictors
that's very important yeah non different
interests not differentiable and while
that it's a problem analytically you
solve it with this Lars algorithm and
when you can use Lars for the lasso you
could use Lars for the elastic net it's
just a slightly modified version of the
algorithm when you do an elastic net or
a lasso in a ridge you get a coefficient
path because depending on the value of
your lambda you could get different
predictors you could get different
values for your for your coefficients
depending where you decide to strike at
lambda draw a vertical line that tells
you how many predictors are left in your
model and it tells you what the value of
those coefficients are we have two
vertical lines here because the glm net
automatically will give you back to
preferable lambdas the lambda that
minimizes your cross-validation error
and the lambda that is doesn't quite
minimize it but it's a it's a it's
within one standard error of minimizing
it but it's a simpler model because
typically simpler is better both of them
are equally valid you could do what you
choose we can revisionist a coefficient
plot like we saw before thank you thank
you James James likes me being official
with the lanyard and everything we can
see here that the coefficient for the
black variable is now around negative
two instead of negative 18 that's a much
bigger improvement but notice here
like our other co efficient plots there
are no standard errors that's because
penalized regression doesn't lend itself
naturally to confidence intervals or to
significance tests that might be a
problem for a traditional statistician
who wants these confidence intervals
wants it significance test but it's not
so much a problem if you're just doing
predictions there have been some recent
advancements in confidence intervals and
significance tests so if you go to
geralyn dude calm / talks my second most
recent talk I discuss some of the new
advancements they've made it's pretty
cool it's still very nascent but they're
getting better comparing this to our
other models notice the difference in
scales you can see where the
coefficients have been shrunk down I
have removed the confidence intervals
from the other ones so you can get a
common sense so everything's on the same
on the same playing field you see for
standard logistic regression the
coefficient for black is negative 18 for
bayesian it's around negative 4 for the
elastic net it's around negative 2 which
one's the best you should go ahead and
use predictive power to decide which
one's the best one to do but there's no
reason that the Bayesian zand the
frequentist can't live in harmony there
is a Bayesian interpretation of penalize
regression everyone can be happy
together you can think of the expression
for penalized regression as the
posterior mode that's the OLS plus the
penalty term is the mode where the
penalty term is the log prior now it's
very important I said mode typically
when you do bayesian regression you're
looking for the posterior mean but here
we're looking for the posterior mode if
it's Ridge regression it is the mean of
the mode of the same but you know
posterior mode is pretty close for the
two most common penalties the ridge and
the lasso the penalty term for the ridge
is beta squared and the prior is a
normal distribution centered at 0 with a
variance of 1 over 2 P times the P
dimensional identity matrix for last
year regression the penalty term is
absolute a beta and the prior is the
Laplace plot Laplace prior also
known as a double exponential and it's
lambda over two times e to the negative
lambda absolute of beta we can visualize
this we have the normal prior on the
left a cosi prior in the middle and the
Laplace prior on the right you can see
how they're different the Laplace prior
is really sharp it really tries to drag
you to zero and it's not to spread out
we're as a normal prior tells you hey go
to zero but you know don't try that hard
and a cosi prior is a slab at zero but
it's really spread out so all these
methods do they're all shrinkage they're
all trying to shrink the coefficients
towards zero that's what I'll centered
at zero so at all they're all trying to
do the same thing it's just that when
you do Beijing regression it's more
you're really putting more thought into
it one variable at a time whereas
penalized regression like hey here's
10,000 variables flatten it out see what
happens let the machine do the work so
some of the benefits are you're going to
get tighter confidence intervals and or
credible intervals and you're getting
stronger predictive power and greater
interpret ability so you get lots of
benefits from this and the cool thing
about penalize regression at least
elastic net you can use it when you have
many more predictors than data which is
becoming a problem nowadays if you want
to learn more here's just some light
reading for you so I highly recommend
you come here these are all clickable
links go through them all these are
papers presentations chapters of books
that let you read about Beijing
regression and penalize regression so
any questions no questions I explained
it perfectly Oh lots lots let's say
you're trying to use anytime you have
many many predictors let's say you have
your doing derivatives trading and you
have you're trying to based on all your
let's say you're trying to do a
multivariate time series where you have
a thousand correlated time series but
that's going to lead to too much
dimensionality so you can use a penalize
regression to restrict your the number
of time series you're comparing that's
one well let's say you have predictors
when you have lots of buckets but some
buckets just don't have a lot of data
that's going to give you why confident
Jules you give it a penalized regression
and I'll shrink it down toward zero and
make it more stable so right there are
two possibilities and Finance path
dependent analysis like longitudinal
there is well bayesian aggression is
great for that that's a hierarchical
model so right there that takes care of
that if you want to use penalize
regression there is a type of penalize
regression for longitudinal models I
think it's called the group lasso I
think that will take care of it if not
it might be the graphical lasso which is
called glass oh so between the two of
those I think you got your solution
anyone else before oh no man i will do a
giveaway i'm not sure how we're going to
figure out how to do it of the Great
American Novel better than catcher in
the rye at least according to my mother
we'll find some way to give away our for
everyone to convert you people to our or
just to enjoy some light reading as you
trying to fall asleep you're right it's
gripping I would not fall asleep but if
someone gets stabbed in the middle then
there's a twist yeah I yeah I would not
fall asleep from this and it's in color
full color yes yes cool well it was
great talking to you guys and hope you
have a wonderful end of the conference
thank you